[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en el espacio porque rusia se
negó a quedarse atrás en la carrera por
el turismo espacial y envió a la
estación espacial internacional al
multimillonario japonés yu sakuma es
agua ya su asistente dio su gira no
junto con el cosmonauta alexander mi
surf kings comandante de la nave soyuz
con esta hazaña el turismo vuelve a esta
instalación por primera vez en 12 años
así hablaba más agua y mister king un
día antes del despegue
nunca pensé que podría ir al espacio me
gustaba mucho el cielo estrellado y los
cuerpos celestes de pequeño 70 edades
que ésta son anaga y me siento
afortunado de tener esta oportunidad y
realmente cumplir mi sueño pero es como
demás sí
estoy seguro de que nuestro tiempo en la
estación espacial internacional será
ocupado y enfocado para nosotros es un
tipo especial de desafío hacer todo bien
en los 12 días que estaremos allí
la estancia de los turistas y el
cosmonauta tiene una duración total de
12 días más agua un magnate de la moda
en línea en su país y su asistente
tuvieron semanas de entrenamiento en la
llamada ciudad de las estrellas un
complejo cercano a moscú donde se
realiza la capacitación de los
aspirantes a cosmonautas tanto rusos
como extranjeros desde los años 60 la
misión fue organizada por roscósmos la
agencia espacial rusa y la compañía
privada estadounidense space adventures
ambos han trabajado en conjunto por más
de 20 años
dejamos este tema atrás y hablamos de un
hallazgo arqueológico que ha sorprendido
a los científicos un equipo de
investigadores chilenos encontró un
fósil íntegro de 74 millones de años de
una nueva especie de dinosaurio
acorazada el descubrimiento se produjo
en la región de magallanes y este
espécimen maravillo a los expertos al
incluir una particular cola que no se
parece a la de ningún ejemplar
catalogado hasta ahora la estructura de
absolutamente electricidad porque la
conecta recubierta de 27 pares de
puestos térmicos 5 de los cuales están
fusionados es prácticamente la mitad de
la cola tapada de su puesto produciendo
un arma esto absolutamente distinta a
todo lo que se conocía para cualquier
pino jauri la nueva especie fue
denominada seguros el enganche ni tiene
una dimensión de alrededor de 2 metros
los expertos indican que la
investigación del fósil permitió
determinar que se trata de un
ankylosaurio transicional es decir un
eslabón evolutivo entre los ankylosaurio
si otros linajes más antiguos de
dinosaurios acorazados
este animal está muy preservado y que
nos permite por fin conocer la anatomía
de un grupo muy enigmático de
dinosaurios acorazados que vivieron en
los confines del hemisferio sur y además
demuestra que existen todo un linaje
todo un grupo que desconocíamos hasta
ahora para la ciencia que probablemente
allí vivió durante millones de años en
el pasado entonces este es el último
superviviente de ese grupo vamos ahora
hasta australia cada vez son más las
iniciativas que están trabajando con
productos vegetales para reemplazar la
proteína animal proyectos que buscan
proteger a los animales y a la vez
evitar una contaminación mayor del medio
ambiente justamente a esto se dedica un
grupo de expertos de la universidad de
queensland en brisbane
los consumidores quieren opciones que
sean más sostenibles que en opciones que
no estén basadas en la carne por motivos
de bienestar animal o faces wind
necesitamos saber la ciencia fundamental
waris qué es lo que hace que una
hamburguesa de carne sea compacta y se
sienta jugosa y elástica en la boca y
cómo replicar todo con proteínas
vegetales simple 'britain's de australia
pasamos a territorio ruso para conocer
una empresa emerge de software que creó
un dispositivo
automatizado para agilizar la entrada en
muchos lugares donde para el ingreso se
requiere verificar los documentos de
identidad de los visitantes y la
autenticidad de los certificados de
vacunación
el dispositivo fue fabricado por la
firma adrià litis y se está probando en
un centro de negocios en san petersburgo
donde el carnet de inoculación es
solicitado para eventos públicos y
gimnasios museos cines y teatros
en primer lugar el dispositivo comprueba
el porte de la mascarilla detecta si
está puesta o no y pide que el usuario
el aporte luego pide el código qr y el
pasaporte para confirmar que los datos
del código y de la identificación son
los mismos
y finalizamos este espacio en la ciudad
de gaza con míster robot un robot hecho
localmente que interactúa con
estudiantes y les enseña sobre circuitos
eléctricos los ingenieros locales
aseguran que se trata de un artefacto
único en su tipo en los territorios
palestinos donde los sistemas y
componentes que lo conforman son
sumamente escasos lo que aumenta el
valor de su rol dentro del sistema
educativo
cuando tuvimos la idea y presentamos el
robot por primera vez en la clase los
estudiantes interactuaron con él de una
forma extraña fue como un sueño hecho
realidad
cuando uniste robots entró al aula
realmente interactúa con los estudiantes
no sólo se movió alrededor sino que se
comunicó con ellos como si fueran amigas
en los audífonos
como su nombre lo indica es el asistente
del profesor y no su reemplazo él asiste
el proceso educativo haciendo preguntas
dando respuestas saludando e
interactuando en todos los aspectos
y
así concluimos esta crónica a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía los invitamos a
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]